I think as you go through your journey
as an actor you start to see other
pieces of production that interests you
for me it was directing having the
opportunity to direct a show that you
have been fortunate enough to be on the
cast of since season one is obviously
this great gift because you know so much
of the show already you know how the
producers and the writers think and
obviously you're very familiar with the
characters and you know the actors very
well you know it's an interesting thing
having to step on the other side of the
camera and all of a sudden you're
talking to actors in a completely
different way your relationship with
them changes you speak their language
obviously as an actor and I could
understand what they're going through
and what they're being asked to do and
you understand maybe a better way or a
simpler way or a more effective way to
get them to do the thing that is needed
the shot that I want is them together in
love getting ready to go on vacation
he's recording her once again he'll a
lot of prep went into directing 4:07
because 4:07 takes place in Mexico you
know now we get to go if see what that
looks like and explore that lens what
does our show look like in a foreign
country what does our show look like not
in LA this is such a la show and it's so
specific to LA in such a love-letter of
LA you look at this you we were on the
water and mountains the work with like a
Mexican production company so like half
our crew only spoke Spanish
[Music]
getting to go explore Mexico with Molly
you made it even that more special for
her own journey as a character I would
say my favorite scene to shoot is Molly
goes on a walk on the beach and makes a
phone call she calls dr. Rhonda it was
probably the most chaotic shot of the
entire time down to Mexico because we
were racing against light molly is in
this very vulnerable place she's on this
beautiful beach and the waves are
crashing but she's alone she's just not
dealing with all the things that are
going on inside her head and not
confronting them and so being able to
capture that moment out on that Beach
was really really special let's reset
good job guys we get something that I
definitely want to keep doing and grow
and learn and I'm so grateful to get the
opportunity and to step into those shoes
on this show especially
[Music]
you